foreign
hey Carolyn welcome to the show
hey thank you for taking my call
of course how can we help
yeah so
um my question has to do with
um Brent versus buying but it's a little
bit more nuanced so
um we're basically in a situation where
we're already renting as cheaply as
possible
um we even had to move over to Summer to
avoid a rent hike that put it way
outside of our budget
um
and we can't seem to follow the 25 of
take-home rule essentially
um our original plan was to rent
um really cheap for a while and have a
big down payment and buy a family home
but now I'm wondering if it would make
more sense to look to buying something
like a condo or a town home
for something close anywhere between
like 80 and 90 000 and going ahead and
purchasing that
um since we can't
get that percentage down to 25 percent
what's your income right now and what's
your rent
um right so our rent right now is 8.25
my I my husband's working he's take home
is about
um 2 200 a month
um we're newly married so we've been
married about a year and four months
um I was working part-time and then I
had her son and I stopped working
um my plan is to be a stay-at-home mom
there are a few things I'm planning on
doing on the side that should bring in
maybe close to 400 a month
um which would bring our I guess our
take-home it's close to 26 2600 a month
okay yeah I don't see this as a you know
I know we the percentages are really
helpful but it's not a legalistic uh
piece of the equation what I do think is
the bigger problem here is the income
there's just not enough coming coming in
you know if you're going to be staying
at home we need to get his income up to
where we're still able to live our life
and invest 15 percent and say for
college for this baby and pay off the
house early and if we can't do that we
need more margin and there's only two
ways to get it make more or spend less
and it sounds like you guys are doing
your very best on the spend less side
yes yeah so we're at the biggest thing
I'm trying to tweak right now is just
groceries
um his job is I mean he's only been
working professionally for two years
um I'm 24 and he's 23.
um and we expect well he's been promised
basically a promotion and race he's
already had one he hasn't been at the
job yet for even a year
um so we expect growth on that end
um what does he do
I'm sorry what does he do for a living
he's a project manager
um so he's he's working for a relatively
new company so they basically hired a
whole bunch of young people and put them
in complicated positions so it's been
good for him he's been able to get a lot
of experience really fast
um the salary isn't there necessarily
yet
um I mean he has a salary but it's not
doesn't really match what he's doing but
the company is growing really fast
so we're hopeful that
he will be able to progress quickly he's
been told that he'll get promoted to a
senior project management position
um by the second quarter of this year
that's good news and so do you guys have
any debt
no we don't have any debt um we already
have an emergency savings built up
um and we have 30 000 already saved for
a down payment wow on top of the
emergency fund
is that right
yeah if you're a fully funded emergency
fund plus thirty thousand
correct yeah we plan on putting a little
bit more in the emergency fund now that
we have a baby but
um how did you guys get to that amount
um I well we saved we were both
homeschooled kids to conservative
parents and
um we were just raised that way I was
able to get through college debt free
and worked all the way through
um he has an associate's degree he's
planning on going back to get a
bachelor's at some point
um yeah I don't know so everything that
I was making before
um I left my job and had a baby we just
put straight into that down payment
that's awesome that's really awesome so
tell us about the condo is that is that
an option that it's like oh man that's
like last resort we're not excited about
it or could you see yourself living in
that condo for a while and being being
content
well not we're not super excited about
it
um our plan will plan now like in the
apartment we were in we got it's it's
small but there's two bedrooms so the
whole plane I was like technically we
could fit three kids in here I mean we
plan on having a large family so
um that that was the plan but then when
I think about condos I mean just I've
looked for there's not very many on the
market right now but just looked around
a little bit basically you can get a
condo that's roughly the same size of
our apartment
um and it's the same sort of deal like
we could manage to live there probably
five years or so
um longer if if necessary but
um what are those condos cost
um it's seems to vary and I'm I'm not as
familiar with the city we're currently
in so part of that I need to look at
like crime maps and stuff
um but roughly they're going for
anywhere between 80 and 90 000. okay
so you guys would have uh if you got the
condo today which you're in a position
to technically do it with 30 000 down on
a 90 000 condo uh that would put you on
a 15-year fix at a payment of about 7 30
or so
right yeah now you do have the extra
cost there may be HOA there's going to
be home maintenance repairs property
taxes home insurance is going to be
higher than renters insurance so you
want to factor all those pieces in but
as far as a financial equation you could
do this
okay and I is it my first home was a
town home and we loved it and you don't
have a lot to worry about with condos
and Townhomes versus single-family homes
so I think it's a great step for you
guys if you really want to get out of
the renting game
okay
um honestly like we're we're renting now
we're pretty content too so I just don't
know if it's smarter financially to get
a condo versus renting so really we're
open to do I just wouldn't be in a rush
for the next five years I mean it is so
wonderful when the toilet breaks you
just call someone and they just show up
and fix it and so there's especially
with a baby uh so there's a lot of great
things about renting there's a it gets a
bad rap but for a lot of situations it's
a good move and long term it's always a
great move to be a homeowner so I would
encourage you to do that but if you want
to save up more and go hey we want a
single family home that's going to be
double the cost we need to wait till we
have a bigger down payment there's a lot
of wisdom in that too when you guys are
good Savers like you guys have saved
quite a bit on a relatively small income
in the grand scheme of things so as your
husband gets raises and you continue to
be aggressive with your finances you
know in a year or two the the
opportunity to get a single family home
maybe within reach while still keeping
it under that 25 percent you know do you
feel in your gut that you would rather
wait it out or do you kind of feel that
rush to buy something
I definitely don't feel a rush to buy
something
um it's just I mean recently it's just
struck us how frustrating it is to just
throw rent money you know out the window
um when we could be putting it towards
something like a condo and then have
that to sell in five-ish years is put
towards a single family home so
yeah I can I can really just see it
going either way so it's it's nuanced
and we haven't just been sure what to do
but I would just set a goal and say hey
year from now we want to be in a
position to buy we here's what we're
kind of looking at and just be about
that savings goal yep and I think you're
in a really great position I love that
this is this is something that could go
either way and you'd be comfortable in
that position I mean you're set up with
a down payment if you want to do a condo
I think you wouldn't go wrong but also
since you aren't in a hurry and you're
content renting you know if you're
willing to wait it out you might be able
to get something that you're a little
bit more excited about in here I think I
think it's a hard one where it's really
going to have to be some soul searching
and what you want to do